some mortal kombat news you all know I'm
a Mortal Kombat fanatic there's no fight
in it so here we go three DLC characters
have been announced today and they are
Kintaro kenchi and the chicken red now
we'll start out with the chicken red cuz
apparently she's scarlet a lot of you
were like who the hell is scarlet and
you're right to ask back cuz no one
knows if you go back to the early 90s
Mortal Kombat 2 was like this cesspool
just the crockpot of rumors and when you
would pick Molina there's a rare bug in
which she would turn red and a bunch of
junior high students were like she's a
new character she's red her name is
scarlet that's it that's fact there was
a rumor for everything in Mortal Kombat
2 there was a rumor that you can climb
in the knothole in one of the trees in
the living forest and fight the Keebler
elves
I heard you could climb into the tree
hole and fight the Keebler elves like I
mean I tried every which way I tried to
fight the Keebler elves it's not in
Mortal Kombat 2 is it I can't fight the
Keebler Elf no you should be able to do
that and Ed Boon did say he wanted to
pay homage to a lot of rumors that were
in Mortal Kombat 1 2 & 3 so it looks
like they made scarlet a reality so if
you're the junior high student who came
up with scarlet a job man you changed
the world
now please clean yourself up and get out
of your meth den and can she can she was
always my favorite from the new Mortal
Kombat's like Mortal Kombat Deadly
Alliance on he's a blind swordsman ninja
with psychic powers that's all sorts of
awesome and if you look in the
background in a couple levels you see
him fighting people so I thought he
might be in it but there are a couple of
people who are in the backgrounds also
that why would they be in it and next we
have Kintaro who's like Goro only way
more hardcore because yeah the teleport
jump and stomp on you you know like
everything that made you wanted to
commit suicide when you were fighting
him he was the cheapest sub boss in the
history of sub bosses and the weird
thing is they made Shiva and more will
combat 3 because everyone wanted to play
as a show con warrior which is what the
four armed guys are but supposedly
Shiva's also in the game and also
kentaro so Dee plasm who knows
I imagine the main thing about
downloadable characters that you get to
play as him why would you download
someone who will just be so hard you
want to kill yourself I don't get that
so expect him to be playable and the
fear about downloadable characters is
that to just nickle and diamond is like
in Marvel vs. Capcom chill and squid man
I don't know his name don't hate me for
it they were already on the disc and you
had to pay to unlock them people hate
that rightfully so but edie boon did say
on Twitter that the DLC characters are
actually not on the disc so you actually
are downloading new things so Ed Boon
and/or the good people at NetherRealm
Studios and Warner Brothers
please don't nickel and dime it too much
don't make it like five dollars a person
I understand you got a business to run
but that would be severely lame so three
DLC characters that's the MK news
do you think about it do you like it -
you hate it you at least respect the
fact that the guys are not on the disk
actually new content and I was just
getting ready to go to bed right now
it's midnight and then a friend of mine
texted me a picture of the character
select screen for Mortal Kombat filled
up and all and if the character shows on
the left is true the holy so I'll
put a link below where you can check it
out warning it shows everyone and
supposedly it's legit if it's a fake
it's a really good fake so check it out
and then come back here comment below
let me know what you think and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]